un
dialogue de sourds devenu un peu plus
bruyant
maintenant que l'avortement n'est plus
un droit protégé par la constitution
américaine des états unis
un consensus est illusoire
cette jeune femme voudrait que les
manifestants anti-avortement fasse
preuve de plus d'humanité
essayez vous de comprendre les femmes
qui choisissent de se faire avorter
demande chief avenue de la virginie où
tentez-vous d'imposer vos doctrine
religieuse au sein de nos gouvernements
où il y à une séparation avec l'état
mais j'étais venu du texas crois que les
personnes anti choix sont aveuglés par
la religion
il faudrait que ces personnes soient des
programmes il dit elle et ceci
n'arrivera pas au cours d'une
manifestation alors qu'ils sont
constamment bombardés de messages
religieux
ces mères de familles disent qu'elles ne
se tairont pas malgré les voix qui
s'élèvent contre l'avortement
[Applaudissements]
chacun demeure campé sur ses positions
vous voulez commettre des meurtres dit
ce jeune homme les nôtres ne sont pas
sécuritaires
toutes les vies ont une valeur nous
avons tous une vie il nous ne devrions
pas être tués ajoute valentina venue de
l'indiana le président américain joe
biden a réitéré son soutien aux femmes
en ajoutant que cette décision
mon administration se penchera sur la
légalité des lois édictées par les
gouvernements anti choix explique le
président ans comme l'interdiction de se
rendre dans un autre état pour obtenir
des soins de santé
partout au pays les américains sont
descendus dans les rues
[Musique]
si vous souhaitez que l'avortement
demeure légale en caroline du sud vous
devez passer à l'action
à jackson mississipi où l'avortement
sera bientôt interdit les manifestants
tentent de décourager le personnel d'une
clinique
jour après jour le fossé se creuse un
peu plus entre les deux camps chacun
étant convaincus de détenir la vérité
ici valérie michaela bayne radio-canada
washington